it's been two weeks since the house
passed the sweeping voting rights
legislation known as the for the people
act
or hr1 and now that bill has been
formally introduced in the senate the
first hearing on the bill is set for
wednesday
it includes provisions like automatic
voter registration same day registration
at least 15 days of early voting
expanded mail-in voting
it also restores voting rights to the
formerly incarcerated
banned gerrymandered district maps
limits dark money and politics
and here's a biggie makes election day a
federal holiday
among other many reforms republicans are
fervently against this bill calling it
federal overreach and an
unconstitutional power grab by democrats
some even falsely suggest it would allow
for illegal voting
they're being very proportionate in
their criticisms of the bill
here's gop senator mike lee on fox news
everything about this bill is rotten to
the core this is a bill as if
written in hell by the devil himself
okay then although the bill has already
passed in the house twice in fact its
chances in the senate with the likes of
mike lee
are pretty slim especially with a
filibuster in place
but with republicans trying to restrict
voting rights at the state level across
the country
activists and even celebrities are
urging congress to do whatever it takes
to pass the for the people act among
them is the outspoken actor and activist
piper perabo who you may know from
movies like coyote ugly or tv shows like
covert affairs
i spoke with her earlier today
piper perabo thank you so much for
joining me on the show
thanks so much for having me
you've been very outspoken about voting
rights in recent weeks and getting
people registered to vote
why is the for the people act hr1 in the
house and now s1
in the senate this week why is it so
important that passes into law asap in
your view well
sr1 which was introduced today would
make
voting more easy and accessible for all
eligible americans and just recently we
had the 56th anniversary
of the march across edmund pettus bridge
for voting rights
and i can't believe that it's been 56
years and we're still
fighting for equality at the voting box
that's longer than i've been alive so i
just
am so hopeful that we can pass this bill
so that every
eligible american has access to the
ballot
yes and we've been talking a great deal
about the bill and its contents on this
show both today and on previous weeks it
is so important
of course there's a lot of resistance to
it the republicans say this bill is
federal government overreach it's just a
naked power grab by democrats what do
you say to them
well i would say that americans don't
have to listen to republicans or
democrats on this bill they can read it
for themselves you can go
to congress.gov and read the entire bill
for yourself so that you know exactly
what's in it
and you don't have to fall for any
headlines or clickbait or
sound bites that politicians tell you
what this bill is about is about
automatic voter registration for all
eligible americans
making sure that there's early access to
the ballot at least 15 days in every
state including a weekend
and time before 9 a.m and after 5 p.m
and mail-in
and mail-in voting which we all saw was
so important during the pandemic so
these are kind of common sense voting uh
rights
that make access to the ballot equal for
everyone
and so it's not really a republican or a
democratic bill i don't understand why
people speak out against it
yeah it's a good point the idea of
having an election day be a federal
holiday that's not a
i'm pretty sure democrats and republican
voters would benefit from that
piper we know this bill has a tough path
ahead especially in the senate but in
the meantime
the brennan center so far identified
more than 250
restrictive voting bills in 43 states
uh a lot of the state legislatures are
run by republicans they have a good
chance of getting those bills through
if hr one doesn't happen you know it's
going to be even more voter suppression
how do activists and organizers like
yourself
how do you fight these restrictions on
the ground in at the state level
i think it's really important that
people understand who their state
representatives are you know especially
on the news at night we talk about
congress and the senate and the
president
and the federal level is important but
they can limit your voting rights at the
state level as well
so especially in these 43 different
states where they're trying to limit
your access to the ballot
voters need to be calling their state
legislatures
and saying they don't want these kind of
bills and i think
legislators really respond to those
kinds of things because especially the
state level they're not used to being
inundated with calls from voters
and they really listen if you're a
constituent they want to hear from you
so talking about uh inundating people
with calls and being an
activist a lot of people watching this
will really only know you from your tv
shows or your movies
have you always been an activist you've
always been politically active
since what age what attracted you to it
i haven't always been politically active
in fact i think part of the reason why
i'm so active now is that i realized i
wasn't paying attention
when trump made those comments on the
access hollywood
bus that were recorded about women i was
so shocked that someone like that
could be running for president of the
united states and i thought for sure his
candidacy would be over as soon as that
was released
and when he became president i realized
that i hadn't been paying attention and
i needed to
pay a lot more attention so i've been
really busy the last year and a half
years
i think really busy is an understatement
and you did a lot of catching up
uh in terms of protests i think we've
got pictures here that we could see you
were actually arrested
after disrupting then supreme court
nominee brett kavanaugh's confirmation
hearing
back in 2018. this week
senator sheldon whitehouse asked
attorney general merrick garland
to look into the fbi background check of
kavanaugh at the time
of that of those hearings and
there's this argument he's putting for
there you are i was just waiting for you
to pop up
the there's this argument that the
accusations of sexual assault against it
were not
properly investigated uh he even went as
far as suggesting the fbi probe was fake
given you were so outspoken at the time
against kavanaugh what do you make of
these allegations now and this idea that
kavanaugh's just sitting on the bench
doling out opinions like any other
justice
well i was opposed to brett kavanaugh as
a supreme court justice
before dr ford came out with her
allegations so i was opposed to him
because of his views against freedom of
choice
and also because at the time the
president was an unindicted
co-conspirator in a felony investigation
and so i didn't think was appropriate
that he be appointing judges at that
time
and then after dr ford came out there
were a lot of concerns about what the
fbi
did to investigate kavanaugh's
background and so i really applaud
senator whitehouse
for coming out on this and asking for
that to be investigated
and if everything was done properly and
is on the up and up then
there's nothing to worry about and if
problems arise they can be investigated
and supreme court justices can be
impeached just like presidents
it's a very good point just like
presidents and president donald trump
got impeached twice
um we just saw sadly horrifically this
week another incident of violence
against women specifically against
asian women in atlanta and we also heard
a police officer basically trying to
explain away the suspect's actions as
quote having a bad day
and suggesting it's not racist because
the suspect said
it wasn't racist um that officer since
apologized for his comments
but it's still kind of indicative of the
underlying misogyny and racism that's
pervasive
in our society that not only leads to
crimes like this but people
offering excuses for especially white
male perpetrators of such crimes
yeah i think it's on all of us to stand
up and speak out about violence against
asian americans right now and
violence and bigotry anywhere in our
country
another actor friend of mine daniel day
kim was testifying for the house
judiciary committee
just today and one of the things he
talked about was the
hate crimes act which is before the
judiciary committee right now
which would do many things but one of
which would provide a streamlined way to
report hate crimes
and it's kind of surprising that in a
country with a history like ours there
isn't
a national hotline or a way to easily do
that
and so um i'm really grateful that that
bill exists and people
can call their members of congress and
tell them that they want to support
the hate crimes act
yes it's so important and i'm glad uh we
could have you here to talk about that
and so much more but we're out of time
piper parabo thank you so much for
joining me tonight i appreciate it
thank you so much for having me i really
appreciate you taking the time
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching